would classify yourself as a.net
developer most of you Java developers
okay JavaScript developers okay some of
you anybody in the room morally opposed
to hand raising okay I always get like
one or two many of you probably are you
just don't know how to express it in the
moment
um okay so right we we kind of live in a
world where you have to be more than one
thing like I saw I saw many people raise
their hands for dotnet and for
JavaScript like you can't just do one
thing anymore and I cut myself off after
Java any PHP some you can be proud PHP
yo um I have live production code
running in WordPress right now um it's
been around for a while so what about
like Ruby yes I've got a couple very
proud of the Ruby developers are always
very proud like I do Ruby they're kind
of like they're kind of like the you
know the vim IDE users anybody code in
VI right they will let you know even if
you don't ask so a friend of mine codes
and VI and it comes up in conversation
regularly about any topic at all where
do you want to go for dinner you know I
code in bi um so alright okay who in the
room is using graph QL right now a
couple okay so the vast majority of this
time I'm going to kind of set the tone
for the talk and you just say if you
want to stay here if you don't want say
whatever I don't care
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna we've
got a I've got a restful api
I'm gonna lay graph QL layer on top of
it and then I'm going to
show you how to do subscriptions and
then we're gonna talk about wrapping in
a function of my master like that's
that's the talk I'm gonna tell you a lot
about just what graph QL is cuz you may
have noticed a few of you raised your
hand most of you did not and so that's
that's about what I normally expect for
this talk okay
but one thing to note those of you who
raised your hands that you do graph QL
today I'm doing some live demo stuff and
so whatever breaks I saw you raise your
hand and you're on the hook to help me
you know figure it out alright um so I'm
John
I am from if you haven't noticed already
America and this is my second time at
Bill stuff so I asked him I love this
conference you guys those of you who are
local you have some fantastic community
organizers who have put together a
pretty awesome event so thank you for
having me in addition to like all the
good people who are out there okay who's
heard of Star Wars right so that's one
thing that's always kind of fun right I
can't no matter where I am in the world
I could say Star Wars and everybody
should know where I'm at so there is a
website called swappi and it took me
longer than I would like to admit that
it stands for the Star Wars API but yeah
so there is a website out there called
swappi that is the Star Wars API and
what the Star Wars API does is basically
it's just a restful api see you down
there you know go to slash people it
gives you a list of people slash people
slash one gives you guess take a guess
who people one gets you Vader
Jeffrey Shaw's what is people slash one
gets you Luke Skywalker no it's the
first person anyway anyway okay right
and there's all this cool data now I am
in a demo a demo environment and the
first rule of a demo environment is
never trust and rely on the Internet
so I have not so I've built my own but I
stole the data from here so I have to
give them credit and I kind of want to
show you what this looks like
so I have a an API of plain restful api
right get people get planets get films
it just does that kind of stuff and if i
open up the browser to localhost 3000
films look at what it gets me i'm you
hope it gets me the opening crawl the
episode ID directors the producers etc
and then if i click on people 1 it gives
me Luke Skywalker and I've got all this
stuff in here right ok so this is the
API that I have and this is the API
we're gonna be playing with over the
course of this demo and then here's the
problem who uses restful api so right
now restful api czar cool don't get me
wrong i'm gonna say some bad things
about them i used them like don't just
because things aren't all awesome
doesn't mean none of it's awesome so
this talk is about graph QL alright and
so we're gonna kind of start with just a
real quick basic Y graph QL right um
those of you who build restful api s--
will agree with me most likely there you
go that most websites look like this
right we have we have a browser a laptop
a desktop of something else that's going
to hit an api on the back end how many
of you do this everyday like this is
right websites iterate over arrays pull
data from a database that's your job
like summed up into small little little
bundle but here's the reality in the
world we kind of live in today now we
have mobile devices that do native apps
right so I have a client where we're
building a browser app we're building a
native app may-maybe we have a watch app
and for some reason I cannot explain
we now have refrigerators that have
their own are in case you want to tweet
something while you're getting something
out of your refrigerator right now
here's the here's the problem with a
scenario is the data that the watch
needs in shape the same as what the
browser needs it better not be right
because if you're putting all that data
down here on the browser or on the watch
then you've got some performance issues
bro right if you've got um if I wanted
to display the film and the name of all
the characters if you remember real guy
only showed it to you for a second but
if you remember what that API looks like
if you want to build a app that shows
the film and the characters in that film
how many API calls you have to make
quite a few alright cuz you've got to
iterate over all the characters in the
film now what some people will say is
just fix your API how many of you own
both the front end and like you
personally own the front end and the
back end and can do whatever you want
all across the board
it's funny how quite a few people still
do a lot of us still don't and you don't
have to be ashamed a like it's okay to
say I own it all but that's kind of the
world we would live in and so a graph QL
does is it puts the power there's a hole
right here by the way just so we're all
clear if I fall down just I'll keep
going it's okay what graph QL allows us
to do is start to decide as a consumer
what the shape of my data looks like
what pieces of data my pieces of sub
data I want to get and as a consumer I
can just do whatever I want so what
anybody want to take a quick guess what
Q L stands for query language right I'm
gonna write a query and I'm gonna go do
this thing it's gonna be awesome alright
so let's look at our Star Wars film real
quick if you recall when you looked at
it you've got this right I new hope
for the crawl all of this stuff if
you're gonna have a query you also have
to have a schema and that's one of the
the cool benefits of graph QL is well or
horrible painful points it depends on
who you are but you have to now as a
JavaScript developer this drive me nuts
I have to define every little thing
about my API are about my data so that
you know what to do and how to use it so
I take this and then I start identifying
what these things are so I have a title
an episode ID and opening crawl and I
define them with a type right now it's
not dotnet types it's not JavaScript
types it's not Java types it's its own
special kind of thing but there's only a
couple of them right ain´t float string
building an ID that's it
objects we'll get to those in a minute
but in float string Billy ID so
basically you take this you say that and
now I have my schema so I take that
schema and I say here's what a film
looks like then I take my query and I
say hey
we have one thing we can do with this
API get films that's all you can do it's
going to return what an array of film
and then I even have to define there's a
lot here that I have to do I have to
define what I'm allowed to filter on I'm
allowed to filter on the director I'm
allowed to filter on the episode ID
that's all I'm allowed to filter on
have this thing Culver's Oliver's last
thing real quick that the resolvers
actually what execute the query I go
write a bunch of code I says hey when
you execute the query get films I'm
gonna go out to my restful api to films
I'm gonna filter my data based upon the
arguments that you pass in and that's it
and we're done okay I am going to build
this I'm going very fast here because
I'm we're gonna like look at code and
we're gonna play around I'm gonna build
this at Apollo who uses Apollo okay I've
got a couple of you so you're gonna help
me with my demo Deb you're gonna help me
with my demo okay we've got it we're in
sync all right
the reason why I use Apollo as opposed
to anything else lots and lots of people
use a pot like this is a bad
representation because when we had two
or three but and the documentation is
fantastic and it's incredibly simple
implementation incredibly simple
implementation so I'm gonna walk through
I'm gonna use Apollo as we do this we're
gonna go okay let's look at code because
that's the part that matters all right
real quick
in my fjs file I have an Apollo server
with my type definitions and my
resolvers I've got my schema look at
this what is my schema saying my schema
says I have a film my schema says I have
a query
get films and that's it director episode
ID and then my Birds Oliver is going to
go do some stuff now I'm going to run
this alright let's play around a little
bit
when I come here I don't want that no
when I come here if if you go hit a
RESTful API for the first time ever how
do you know what you can do
kind of a trick question because you
can't write I mean unless they document
it really well now writing Docs
there's several talks on writing Docs
right some Docs those are important
however wouldn't it be awesome if for
the first time I hit an API I can like
have Docs that are already built but
tell me do up Swagger's pretty great yep
but here I have without writing any code
to do it
I have Docs that says hey I can execute
a query call get films that's gonna
return a type of film and here's all the
stuff but that I can pull out of that
right I have all my schemas right here
everything's built in and then we do
this okay so I say query
while Korea may executing
films and then waiting for me what do
you want to see what information do you
want to see
title title makes a lot of sense if
you're paying attention what do you
notice like if this came out of the box
at Apollo this little editor that I have
right here
I didn't you can turn it off but I don't
turn it off for development for obvious
reasons it's got I guess it's got to
tell a sense which is fantastic okay I'm
gonna run this
and look at that get films and you hope
George Lucas that's all
but I I can define the stuff that I want
and that's that's the easy part that's
easy
what if I only who's your favorite Star
Wars director let's be clear about this
real quick
there is no I mean like I'm not even
gonna take answers because there's only
one so here I have the others and I have
George Lucas now I just have the George
Lucas's right ok so this is pretty
simple and straightforward and those of
you who use graphic you all already you
know this already this is super easiest
but it took very little code to make
this thing happen
the beauty of graph QL comes not when I
have one thing right I have films I can
just hit slash films I probably have a
filter on that that's fine whatever when
I start wanting to do you know remember
I had characters
I don't characterize yet because they
don't have that code
but what I want to start having the
subtypes the sub-objects okay because
remember a film didn't look like this
and my restful api a film look like this
I had characters and planets and
starships and all of these things and my
restful api has to go it's got a pick
through all the ones that I want like
characters I've got a t1 oh all right I
don't have a t1 of them in this
particular movie I just have a lot of
them and so what you end up doing is you
end up adding those to your schema and
building out new things so characters
are an array of people planets or an
array of planets so on so forth this
bracket right here means array very
importantly because a person looks like
this homeworld is a planet but it's only
a single planet it's not an array of
planets so I can have a type of object
just like that all right how do you do
this sub revolvers are are pretty
straightforward you end up with a whole
lot of stuff that looks like this this
is small and you in the back can't read
it so I'm gonna you know make it bigger
he's gonna look like this right so you
have a film remember I had query get
films and I just put my resolver in
there now in the context of film I have
more I have a planets resolver and in
the context of film my planets resolver
takes a error is passed in a film and
then it just goes and and pulls the list
of planets and filters those based upon
whatever is in my films and then I end
up with a lot of them I've got a planets
resolver characters resolver starships
is over and so on and so forth
so what'd you end up with
is this now I have well let's go real
quick to my schema look I've added I've
got my film I've got my planet my people
my starships my vehicles all of that
stuff is all now to fight still only
maguet films my resolver now I have this
film with characters in it so I can go
and I can go get people um let's run
this and then I want to show you
something else so if I go into my nodejs
and I pull this up and I hit this same
thing again
I got a refresh and I run that we've
added people right
we want to see everybody's name
so in the new hope you have Luke
Skywalker c-3po r2d2 Darth Vader so on
and so forth over on the other screen I
had my
when I run this how many times did I go
get people
four times why did I go get people four
times because I had four films right so
when it goes against the films and then
for each film it goes and makes an API
call to people to go get a whole bunch
of more stuff if I only had the one it
would only do it once I'm still making
the same RESTful API calls but I would
if I was on the browser on the front end
why is this better there's a big
difference between making multiple API
calls from your back-end server to a
back-end server than it is from the
browser to the back-end server right and
so yes I'm still making the same API
calls to my restful api but instead of
making them across the wire from my
browser or my watch all the way back to
my restful api in my in my JavaScript
application now I'm doing it all from
the backend which makes a huge
difference but what happens when I now
want to say hey
not that
what happens when I want to go get their
planet like I want to get their
homeworlds that's not gonna work because
they don't have my resolver yet
but I kind of keep going and this this
actually continues to get slightly worse
because now what do we have to do to
make this happen
so I have my film that's gonna go pull
characters I don't have to create
another resolver in the context of
people right and that's gonna pop I mean
it's people with the resolver of type
playing it
that's gonna make this stuff happen
now notice do people have Planet Center
people have home world's home moral home
world's singular they have one home
world so hey when you go get home
world's my people resolver is gonna do
what's it gonna do it's gonna go hit
planets that's unfortunate because now
it's going to happen
you
Tatooine it's see-through reveals
homeworld really Tatooine yes it is we
agree on that okay I didn't really pay
attention too much once I got to those
later movies because they weren't super
awesome if you like them a lot I'm sorry
I'm not I'm sorry that you liked them
I'm sorry that I'm probably being
offensive to you but that's okay but
look here this now is a problem because
I went and hid planets on a whole bunch
of times and I and I'm making the same
API call over and over again because
they it's like a lot I had films people
a couple of times and planets for every
film for every person I went and hid
planets again and so that's that's less
than ideal and so what we actually want
to do this is where okay I had a client
who we wanted to use graph QL because we
had something that was similar to to
this situation right we've got multiple
things that want to hit the same API the
API kind of existed already we want to
hit we want to set a graph QL layer on
top of it to kind of do it and they went
out on the internet and did a Google
search for graph QL do you know what the
first four results they found when they
did it graph QL performance problems
graph QL performance is terrible it's
horrible all of these things and they
said well we did a Google search this is
a literal conversation that happened
between between our team and the CTO of
a very large organization the CTO said I
did a Google search on graph QL and the
performance is bad so you can't use it
okay
so the reason why you one of the reasons
there's a lot of reasons but one of the
reasons why you get bad performance is
you end up doing ridiculous things like
this and you
pay attention you don't really really
think about it and so what we want to
kind of get into as we start to walk
through that I did homeworld I did the
sub resolvers is using data loaders
those of you who use graph QL tonight do
you do any kind of data caching or
something like that to prevent the
multiple queries on a resolver with
Apollo this stuff comes built-in which
is kind of awesome and I like it a lot
and so what what Apollo will do for you
is it will go it'll call that planets
and anytime that request needs to call
that API again it just returns the same
result over and over again if if that if
a different request needs to go call an
API out-of-the-box it won't do it you
can cache the data you can do whatever
you want but out of the box Apollo gives
you kind of that fun thing and it does
that this way
so we have this thing called a data
source
Apollo data source arrests there are
lots of these there's Apollo data source
MongoDB there's Apollo data source
reddit I mean there's a whole bunch of
different ones that exist out there but
just out of the box I say hey Apollo
data source rest check this out my base
URL is this and I create functions that
just go and get the api's now it'll pass
IDs it'll do all that stuff too for you
but for the purposes of demo I left it
as simple as I could just to explain but
here we go
I now have this data source my resolvers
now look like this so
so they used to look like this right
where it was Axio stuck yet I was
pulling films that I had it then it was
promises it was all terrible and I
didn't like any of it now they look like
this
I just pulled my data sources from a
context my Star Wars API get films
I now have films and everything just
kind of works out of the box and so now
when I do
you
just so you believe me hold on they
clear my screen
when I hit go
now I just made three API calls instead
of a whole bunch of them
down here
just the three right because it it may
instead of making it always made one but
it made four calls to people so it now
it doesn't do that anymore and then it
made however many calls to planets and
now it just makes the water it caches it
and it does it over again
alright so if I go through that
that's the easy part right
that's selecting data and going out and
you're pulling data and you're just you
know building out a simple application
that displays stuff how many of you get
away with only ever displaying data and
you never have to change anything and
you don't have to take user input or
anybody does anybody get to live in that
world I do not and so
what we end up doing is so in the
restful world what do you do to change
data how does the rest how does rest do
this
hmm patch yo put posts patches my favor
I like that I like the fact that you
said patch first because a lot of people
don't implement that and it makes me
very sad or or they don't do it properly
I'm not gonna talk about that because I
don't want to like go sideways but
correct so rust is very verb based right
so I have I have get to go get data I
have posts to add data I have put to
change data or patch to change data and
but they're not always implemented that
way anyway so back to in graph QL we
have queries and we have mutations and
what mutations do is modify data that's
their whole job right and so same thing
remember I have a type of query and I
have a type of mutation and then I go in
same way and I just say hey I can change
the population of a planet or I can add
a new planet or I can add a character or
I can out of film and then I say hey
here's what you pass it now you can pass
it an object so you can pass in types
you can do kind of what you want here
but that's how that works and then you
go when you building mutation so in the
case of change population I've got I
have to go and find my planet and then I
have to alter the population of said
planet
all right so for the purposes of of this
I'm actually going to kill that one
because now we're gonna start like
changing data and playing around a lot
and I want to do this differently same
basic idea just slightly different
where's my mutation here's my mutation
so
change population I'm going to go change
it and go from there hey also have added
a new query called get planets because
now I thought it doesn't make any sense
to change the population of a planet if
I can't go and get a planet so let's do
that real quick
refresh
you
all right how do i how do I do that
as do
and I want the name
of the planet boom oh and I want the
population of a planet yep
and that's it so my mutations are gonna
be kind of the same thing and the cool
kind of the cool thing about is you all
kind of wrap it together I come over to
my docks I said hey I have a change
population that's how that works so I'm
going to come back over here and I'm
just going to do mutation
I'm gonna do
you
population who do we want to mess with
let's change the population of
you
um well unchanged who do I want to
change the population of all the other
ones you're going right to it in
fairness that they only did blow up one
planet right I mean they could have
blown up a lot more they only did one
zero would have been better
in fairness yes zero is a better option
of planets to destroy than one does the
Death Star count as a planet no because
then the rebels actually didn't destroy
any planets they destroyed a small moon
oh okay
traitorous thing here's ready to change
population population mm URL for and I
get an error BL change population of
type planet must has a selection of
subfields because a mutation works just
the same way as a query like I'm gonna
go change something but then at the same
time I have to say I want the name of
the planet I have to say I want the
what I want population so I make sure
that it worked and I want the URL the ID
of that planet is this gonna work when I
run it oh you can't see it there's a
little red thing right here that says
this is horribly broken that gives me a
nice error I have to
you
oh that's right for some reason who has
ever worked with a stupid API one more
thing I have to change oh please
you
for some reason the population of a
planet is a string if that makes sense
you
I can hear the camera clicking as I'm
fixing my broken demo that's like that's
super awesome okay
there we go I have successfully changed
the population of the planet hoth
because I'm not going to go there quite
yet to three to thirty thousand right
and that's kind of how that's how
mutations work all right I just changed
population I pass it in go like that and
now everything's going the same way and
then I can come over here and I can just
do query get planets
name
population boom there we go now one
thing to point out and I kind of glossed
over this I'll come back to it if I
change this to that I get errors and it
actually will do validation for me right
so wouldn't it be cool if you're doing
just a basic REST API call and like it
did type validation on all your
parameters and and all of that kind of
stuff so that's that's built it the fact
that you have a schema and you define
everything up front which is I know as a
JavaScript developer sounds weird
because the last thing in the world I
want to do is define everything upfront
but that's what we do
makes me have cool stuff like this or I
can say okay here's why it's broken and
here's here's why I want to go with it
all right now we've made it through this
you know the normal stuff and you guys
might be saying well if I recall
properly the name of this talk is
building real time server less api's not
building like simple api's so how many
of you have ever had to write
a a front-end I had where if the day
that changes on the back end you need to
let your user like update the screen
well how do you do that you like pull
over and over again or you do that which
is spoiler so like yes give give me a
second and we'll get there but right you
so I have I have written like heartbeat
queries or polling queries it just says
hey every 30 seconds go and ping if that
doesn't scale super well like if you
have you know hundreds of thousands of
users all long polling the backend API
to see if their message has come through
yet
you don't want to do that
so what graph QL does using WebSockets
is sub this idea of subscriptions so our
mutations I have queries well I also
have this thing called subscriptions and
what subscriptions will do for me is it
will allow me to request some data
and then every time that data changes
it's going to push that resulting data
change out to everybody who subscribed
using WebSockets
so I guess same way as before we have
time query we have type mutation we have
type subscription and I'm gonna watch
for changes in planets all right if a
planet changes I want my suit I want a
subscription notification that says hey
this planet changed and okay that's
awesome and we've used this thing called
pub/sub those things I was coming in I
would have just a second ago because my
demo was broken and we'll fix it and so
basically we have this this subscription
model that says hey a subscription is
going to subscribe to a specific Channel
planet change and every time somebody
changes the planet I'm gonna publish to
it and then it's going to go and push
that data out to everybody all right
so I'm gonna uncomment these okay right
I've got
planets changed my query I've got
pub/sub up here when I subscribe to
something I am subscribing to planets
changed
so when when a subscription is done it
just subscribes to something
when a population on a planet changes
you
what does it do it just publishes the
changed planet and that's all you have
to do and so
real quick I'm going to do that and it's
going to Oh
you
you
you
all right
you
you
you
you
address in use
I don't even know how that's possible
it's this it's it snowed thanks thanks
for that
there we go
yay when in doubt turn it off turn it
back on again because you all noticed
that's all I did there we go
okay so I changed the population of Hoth
to 3,000 I changed the population of
Hoth to 30,000 there it goes I'm gonna
pull this in like this and I am going to
add another one localize 40,000 and I'm
going to instead of a mutation I'm gonna
do a subscription and I'm going to
subscribe to planet changed
and I want the name I'm at the
population and I want the URL I'm gonna
hit go and it's gonna just sit there and
listen and it's not gonna do anything
but when I come over here and I changed
my population of HOF to a lot notice all
of a sudden on its own it pulled up the
new data so WebSockets is just push him
and it was four lines of code to make
that happen it just does it with pub/sub
and all that now you can have more
mutations they have lots of them and so
you
you
you
Oh
so when the Death Star does finally get
there right so now down here at the
bottom it's now called asteroid belt
which is very unfortunate um okay so
that's the description that's right so
the whole I I was actually I gave this
talk on Monday and somebody came up to
me afterwards and said well I don't I
don't have any you know real-time
updates and I owned the API so why
should I switch as though you're just a
browser or just a web app is that yes
that you shouldn't like it doesn't make
any sense for you to do that because you
don't you're gonna take advantage of any
of the benefits of this most of the time
the the advantage to graph QL and where
you want to start using it is is in
three scenarios one if you don't control
the API and you want to push some of
this query into the backend graph kill
is a great option if you need the
real-time updates which was a scenario
we had there are other ways to do
WebSockets absolutely but they're
they're baked into graph QL this is
standard for them and that's super
awesome and right so that's that's kind
of where you want to go right is if if
you're in kind of those scenarios then
that's where you want to start doing it
the beauty of Apollo is that you also
and who uses as your as your out of the
box today just a you guys are not in
sync at all who uses a sure today okay
excellent
AWS okay oh that was actually pretty
even usually I get far more AWS than I
do a sure unless I am at a dotnet
conference if I'm at a dotnet conference
everybody uses Azure and they're like
what's AWS I haven't heard of that
before
um even though AWS owns like 90% but I
of the box um Apollo gives us as your
function support who uses Iser functions
right so native as your things instead
of going in and you know just keeping
your application as it is in a container
and just pushing it up like use the
native Azure stuff and what what as what
Apollo does out of the box is actually
just allows us instead of pulling in as
your server or Apollo server I just
pulled on Apollo server function and do
the same thing my type deafs my
resolvers my data sources everything
just works
I didn't I changed nothing except I set
up a new function and now instead of
node start you do this func host start
and everything just works I now I'm
wrapped in and as your function I can
push it up so you can build your whole
graph QL API make it all work it is
super awesome and then wrap that in an
azure function and deploy it up to Azure
and it all just works so all right
I answered the question and nobody even
I didn't even see that happen so I have
the the question is are there scenarios
where you would recommend to use rest
instead of graph QL yes I actually is
did I who asked that question and did I
answer the question nobody wants to
admit they asked the question it was a
really good legitimate question right
because again I want to be kind of clear
with this just like we have net and we
have JavaScript's and we have all these
other things and we have different tools
that kind of go in the toolbox if you're
doing a a standard API that you just go
and pull data and you change data and
it's used it by one source and the
thought and rest is great the rest is a
standard that everybody uses it's five
most of the API is on the Internet our
rest when you start to hit the scenarios
where you have multiple things or the
third remember I said three but then I
also told you to choose the three the
third reason why you use graph QL and
this is where we use it quite a bit I
have multiple disparate systems and I
need to aggregate data from all of those
systems and then push that data back up
to to a browser or an amp that's another
great scenario for graph QL but if
you're doing a basic API REST API works
just fine right if you also want the
discoverability the the schema and all
of that stuff that's where graph QL
comes in pretty well all right so if you
have questions let me know like you can
come up and we can chat about it at time
almost so I don't want to like hold
everybody but if you have questions come
let me know otherwise the whole point of
this talk is to take a whole bunch of
usually none of you had done graph QL
before like graph QL is not hard it
actually works pretty well and Apollo
Doc's are phenomenal
so so take a little bit of time go look
at the Apollo docks and play around with
it and you will love it very very
quickly so alright thank you guys very
much
if you have questions come up a seat